[Musique]
et si et si on mourait en paix avec la
vie un tremblement de terre un accident
de train des scènes de guerre des
attentats la mort est partout diffusée
en continu presque banal impersonnel
lointaine et puis parfois elles vous
touchent de près et là elle devient
insupportable douloureuse mais pourquoi
je suis médecin réanimateur je m'occupe
de patients dans des états graves en
essayant de leur faire passer ce cap
critique la mort a toujours été associée
pour moi à des histoires d'amour mes
parents mais m on métier mes patients
tout ce qui a fait ce que je suis
aujourd'hui alors la mort je vais vous
la raconter c'est un peu l'histoire de
ma vie j'avais 22 ans j'avais toujours
rêvé de faire du ca but sauver des vies
patrick était le patron du samu m'avait
dit si pendant toute la durée de temps
dexter a tu fais une garde par semaine
avec moi je t'emmène avec moi je te
forme
ça fait six mois qu'on travaille
ensemble
un dimanche de garde le téléphone sonne
il faut y aller on part on entre dans le
patron dans le camion patrick me regarde
me dit aujourd'hui c'est toi qui fais
ton aujourd'hui c'est toi qui fait
tousser
angoisse qui vous étreint vais-je
réussir on est dans le camion en avance
le titre maison de banlieue
monsieur bien mis un certain âge devant
la porte avec sa cravate vous attend
c'est ma femme on était en train de
regarder la télévision tous les deux et
puis elle ne bouge plus on rentre dans
la pièce madame françoise est allongé
sur le canapé immobile elle semble
paralysé elle ne réagit plus sa
respiration est bruyante
ça booste efforts mais laisse couler sa
salive je sais intubation ventilation
régulation c'est mon métier je me
précipite
j'attrape pour ça que je sors matériels
humains se pose sur mon épaule me
mobilise la main se fait plus lourde
une voix me murmure à l'oreille et ils
voient que vas tu faire c'est patrick
igor que vas tu faire elle a 90 ans elle
a fait un accident vasculaire cérébral
peut rien faire elle va mourir vient
allant voir son mari on a été voir son
époux et patrick lui a expliqué il a
expliqué que madame avait fait un
accident vasculaire cérébral massif et
que s'il en était d'accord on le
laisserait à la maison on allait appeler
son médecin traitant pour qu'ils
viennent poursuivre la prise en charge
et puis qui pouvait appeler ses enfants
qu'ils soient présents monsieur nous a
offert un café on a discuté en attendant
le médecin traitant presque amicalement
sereinement et puis on est rentré
madame est parti dans la nuit entourée
de sa famille et pourquoi ce jour-là -
médecin réanimateur
je n'ai rien fait et pourquoi bien que
fidèle à mon serment d'hippocrate ce
jour là je n'ai rien fait médecin
réanimateur sauveur dernier rome a
décidé avant dieu
ce jour là je n'ai rien fait droit de
mourir droit d'aimer ce jour là j'ai
oublié le jeu j'ai appris le nous j'ai
transformé le tuer en nous sommes tout
simplement
et puis des années plus tard cette fois
je suis chef dans un service de
réanimation
c'est l'hiver il fait froid un dimanche
encore toujours le dimanche
il fait froid le ciel est gris les vers
16h le samu m'appelle pierre 16 ans
circulait en scooter rentrer chez lui
percuté par un camion comme à d'emblée
son coeur bat encore il la mène je le
reçois il est beau seize ans dans la
force de l'âge une cicatrice sur le
front un pansement sur le front la joues
tu veut bouffer la vie où tu veux tout
vivre dans le coma une machine pour
respirer un coeur qui bat aucune
réaction coma profond
je sais c'est grave je vais voir sa
famille dans la salle d'attenté
quelques mots et les hurlements la
douleur que qui vous emplit dont vous ne
savez pas quoi faire
et puis son père qui s'approche de moi
qui me dit vous allez le sauver docteur
vous allez le sauver je les emmène voir
tiers allongée sur son lit dans la
chambre de réanimation la machine pour
respirer qui fait lentement son nourrit
son coeur qui bat le scope qui bat il y
est allé expliquer qu'on peut être mort
avec le coeur qui bat on a fait tous les
examens dans l'après midi jusqu'au début
de la nuit et puis
l'électroencéphalogramme et plats
l'intérieur
si cérébrale ne passe pas le scanner
montre des lésions irréversibles
il est mort mais son coeur bat et son
coeur bat donc peut-être il peut aider
d'autres personnes à vivre
alors je suis allé revoir la famille est
là mais hurlements effroyable et puis le
sidération le silence et là tu dois
reprendre ton cas continuez expliqué
alors je leur ai expliqué que mineur il
fallait l'autorisation des parents mais
que si l'on était d'accord ils pouvaient
donner ses organes et peut-être sauver
d'autres vies
la maman regarde regarde le papa regarde
de nouveau ces nombres docteur puis se
relève mais vous nous demandez de toute
façon on l'a vu tout à l'heure son coeur
battait il respirait son coeur bat et on
veut le voir tout de suite
alors je suis retournée dans la chambre
patrick était allongé sur le lit
j'ai débranché les machines et comme son
coeur battait encore je savais qu'il ne
comprendrait pas j'ai pris de seraing
que j'ai mis ce qu'il fallait et j'ai
injecté et son coeur s'est arrêté de
battre et j'ai fait entrer la fin
et j'ai injecté mais pourquoi je suis
rentré dans mon bureau il était 3 heures
du matin j'appelle patron chef chef j'ai
tué quelqu'un un chef j'ai tué quelqu'un
le silence au bout de la ligne puis le
cal vasile raconte son histoire
non il était mort le diagnostic était
certain d'une mathieu personnes il était
mort le diagnostic de mort cérébrale et
est certain par contre le geste rui le
geste tu vas devoir vivre avec ce geste
là tu vas le payer
le payer tu vas vivre avec tout le
talent mais il était bon tu n'as rien
fait qui aurait pu laisser le temps au
temps partagé expliqué peut-être qu'avec
le temps la famille aurait pu partager
aussi sa douleur et puis peut-être au
final accepté ce jour là j'ai oublié le
loup j'ai gardé le jeu j'ai changé le
droit de mourir en droit de tuer
des années plus tard cette fois avec
l'expérience du métier on al impression
qu on commence à devenir un peu fier ne
soit pas fier de cette fierté qui vous
permet de vous exiler mais simplement
fière de sentir qu'on ça pèse que la
réussite intérieur de qui justifie tout
ce qu'on a fait tout c'est moi tous ces
années de travail
le sentiment d'arriver enfin à faire
quelque chose gérard à 50 ans gérard est
hospitalisé le service ça fait trois
mois à peu près qu avec sa femme ils
vont de médecins médecin d'hôpital en
hôpital
on lui a trouvé une masse dans le ventre
dans le poumon et il devait être opéré
pour faire un diagnostic de cette masse
et proposer un traitement
et puis le jour de l'intervention son
coeur s'est emballé et il n'a pas pu
être opéré et dans le service pour ça ça
fait dix jours à peu près qu'il est dans
le service au coeur s'est stabilisée les
choses vont plutôt bien on va pouvoir
essayer d'emmener d'avancé sur le
diagnostic
cette nuit gérard a saigné saignements
isoler le matin je faire un scanner en
urgence pour essayer de comprendre et on
découvre une extension de volumineuses
de cette masse qui lui prend tout le
ventre inopérable selon le chirurgien
peut-être une fibroscopie pourrait
permettre de faire le diagnostic ou
d'avancer ou de proposer peut-être un
traitement la nuit suivante et pire
gérard enseigner on l'a transfusés il
est stable au matin apaiser les choses
sont stabilisés il est 5 heures du matin
j'appelle son épouse elle me dit docteur
ne fait rien attendez moi elle arrive
dites moi docteur mon mari traite depuis
trois mois avec une maladie donc
on n'a pas le diagnostic il traîne
maintenant depuis un mois avec des
essais de diagnostic qui n'avance à rien
et on lui a trouvé une masse dans le
ventre une masse d'entremont le tout
inopérable il vous voulez le transférer
leurs voiliers demain vers une
fibroscopie pour pourquoi est-ce que
vous pensez que ça c'est quelque chose
alors on a été voir gérard gérard était
dans sa chambre il tenait la main de son
épouse il savait il savait déjà
ils ont pris la décision de ne rien
faire gérard rester dans le service et
puis on allait lui apporter du confort
pour que tout ça se passe le mieux
possible mais gérard m'a dit j'aimerais
bien que que vous en parler à mes
enfants alors je suis allé voir ses
enfants avec son épouse est le même
hurlements la douleur qui qui vous
marquent à jamais puis la sidération
et puis il mes docteurs
ça va durer combien de temps
et la réponse est un peu de temps le
plus souvent dans mon expérience
quand les gens sentent que c'est le
moment quand ils ont exprimé tout ce
qu'ils ont à exprimer ils s'en vont
alors le service était ouvert 24 heures
sur 24
la famille de gérard pouvait dormir là
et chaque jour quand on faisait la
visite avec gérard on discute et on
augmenter un petit peu la sédation pour
qu'il ne souffre plus son frère est venu
un jeudi de l'étranger il avait pas
réussi à venir il est venu jeudi il a vu
gérard et gérard nous a quittés dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi
sa femme nous appelait quelques semaines
plus tard pour nous remercier aimé
partager accompagner les mots
aujourd'hui prennent tout leur sens
droit de mourir droit d'aimer 3
d'accompagner à mourir pas de tuer
médecin réanimateur passeur imaginer
imaginez que pour gerra j'ai utilisé la
seringue
imaginez que pour pierre je n'ai pas
utilisé les freins
imaginez que pour françoise j'ai utilisé
la sram
je sais aujourd'hui on peut vivre en
paix avec la mort ou mourir en paix avec
la vie alors si je devais mourir demain
je sais que nous pourrions tous est
d'accord pour qu'on me traite avec
dignité
on me traite avec humanité et qu'on
partage
la vérité c'est par ce partage que le
jeu devient nous que le tuer devient
nous sommes et c'est ce nous qui nous
nourrit et si tour nous nourrir on
remplace la lettre n par la lettre m
alors le droit à mourir devient amour et
rires je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]